¿Cuál es la razón de cambio promedio de
"y" de "x" sobre el intervalo
donde "x" es mayor que -5 y menor que - 2?
Entonces si "x" es menor a -5,
entonces "y" de "x" es igual a 6,
y cuando "x" es igual a -2,
"y" de "x" es igual a 0.
Entonces para conocer la razón de cambio promedio
la razón de cambio promedio de "y" de "x" con respecto,
y podemos asumir que es con respecto a x,
esto va ser el cambio de "y" sobre ese intervalo,
sobre el cambio de "x" sobre este intervalo.
El símbolo para el cambio
es este triángulo delta,
delta "y",
solo escribiré "y",
aunque puedo escribir "y" en función de "x",
delta "y" cambio de "y",
sobre nuestro cambio en "x".
Esa va a ser nuestra razón de cambio promedio
sobre este intervalo,
así que,
¿cuánto cambia "y" en este intervalo?
"y" fue de 6 a 0,
entonces podemos ver esto
como nuestro punto final.
Entonces este es nuestro final y este es nuestro inicio.
Y si lo hiciéramos de la otra manera,
podríamos tener un resultado consistente también,
así que como éste
es el más grande de la lista,
llamémoslo nuestro inicio.
Y esta es su "x" con el valor más bajo,
entonces éste será nuestro inicio
y éste será nuestro final.
Entonces empezamos en 6 y terminamos en 0,
así que el cambio en "y" va a ser -6,
disminuimos 6 en la dirección "y",
entonces es -6.
Podríamos decir que es 0 menos 6
y nuestro cambio en "x" es de -5 a -2,
incrementamos 3...
entonces incrementamos en 3,
así cuando aumentamos "x" en 3
disminuimos "y" en 6,
o si queremos simplificar esto que está aquí,
-6 sobre 3 es igual a -2,
entonces, nuestra razón de cambio promedio de
"y" de "x" sobre el intervalo,
donde "x" es mayor a -5
y menor a -2 es -2.
Entonces cada vez en promedio que
"x" incrementa en 1, "y" disminuirá en 2.